what do you make of just as a small sort
of
a side in human history perhaps it's a
big one
is the nft the non-fungible tokens do
you find those interesting technically
or is it more interesting on the social
side of things
well both i think you know i think it's
um
nfts are actually great right so you
have always um
you're an artist to create um a song or
you could be
um a mom a piece of art
um he has a many unique representation
right over of
a unique uh piece where there is an
artifact of uh
something dream up by you and uh and as
unique representation but now you can
trade
and allow and the important part is that
now you have a visa
not only the nfts themselves but the
ability
to trade them quickly fast
securely knowing that who who owns
which rights and vetting gives a totally
new opportunity for
content creators to be communicator for
what do they do
so but ultimately you still have to have
that scalability security
uh and decentralization to to make it
you know to make it work for bigger and
bigger applications
correct yeah yeah i still wonder what
kind of applications are yet to be
like enabled by it because so much the
interesting thing about
nft is you know if you look outside of
art
is uh just like money you can start
playing with different social
constructs is you can start
playing with the ideas you can start
playing with um
with even like investing somebody was
talking about almost creating an economy
out of uh
like uh creative people or influencers
like if you start a youtube channel or
something like that
you can invest in that person and you
can start trading their creations
and then almost like create a market out
of people's ideas out of people's
creations out of
the people themselves that
generate those creations and there's a
lot of interesting possibilities of what
you can do
with that i mean it seems ridiculous but
you're basically
creating a hierarchy of value
maybe artificial in the digital world
and are trading that but in so doing are
inspiring people to
create so maybe uh
as a sort of our economy gets better and
better and better
where actual work in the physical space
uh becomes less and less in terms of its
importance maybe we'll completely be
operating in a digital space where
where these kinds of economies have more
and more power
and then you have to have this kind of
blockchains
to the scalability security and
decentralization
and decentralization is of course the
tricky one
because uh people in power start to get
nervous
absolutely once in power you always
never be supplanted by somebody else
but this is your job see you in
relations you don't have a job the top
job but now everybody wants it
you